repartira pas à Kiev les mains vides
après Rome Berlin et Paris les
Britanniques lui promettent donc des
centaines de missiles pour sa défense
anti-aérienne mais aussi des drones
d'attaque indispensables en vue de la
contre-offensive David Gilbert
ambiance champêtre pour cette étape
britannique de la mini tourner
européenne de volodimeerski le président
ukrainien atterrit dans les jardins de
la résidence de campagne du Premier
ministre richiss una qui accueille à
bras ouverts un allié soutenu par
Londres depuis le début de l'offensive
russe
le courage et la détermination de votre
pays est une inspiration pour nous tous
j'ai hâte de discuter de ce que nous
pouvons faire de plus pour soutenir
votre pays d'abord merci beaucoup vous
nous avez déjà énormément soutenu vous
avez fait beaucoup vous et votre
gouvernement
d'autant que riches una qui avait
annoncé peu avant la rencontre la
livraison prochaine à Kiev de centaines
de missiles entières et de drones
d'attaque de longue portée qui
s'ajoutent au missile promis la semaine
dernière en tout 5,3 milliards d'euros
d'aide militaires ont déjà été fournis
ou promises par les Britanniques mais
volodières zellenski continue d'espérer
des moyens aériens jusqu'ici refusé par
ses alliés occidentaux oui
nous voulons créer cette coalition
d'avions de chasse et je suis très
optimiste à ce sujet nous en avons parlé
et je pense que dans un avenir proche
vous serez mis au courant de décision
très importante
Londres semble désormais ouvert à cette
perspective évoquant même la prochaine
formation des pilotes Ukrainiens en dans
ce passage au Royaume-Uni comme à Rome
Berlin et Paris pendant le week-end
permet à volodimeers zellenski de
remercier pour le soutien apporté
jusqu'ici et de valider de nouveaux
engagements de fournitures d'armes
dimanche soir le dîner à l'Élysée avec
Emmanuel Macron a été l'occasion pour
Paris de confirmer un nouvel envoi de
blindé et Charles léger mis à part
l'armement fourni par les États-Unis
c'est en Allemagne que la contribution
allait fort de guerre ukrainien et le
plus substantiel il s'élève désormais à
17 milliards d'euros dont une nouvelle
livraison record de 2,7 milliards
annoncé ce